我就先开始说了
然后这个这周我觉得其实讲一下
因为上一周没有特别多的经济数据
那个这一周呢就星期二的时候会出来那个通商的数据
那个现代市场比较关心
就我说一下我对市场整体的一个感觉的看法
然后再结合一下最近一些Tag公司方面的一些变化
现代市场的非常关注这通商数据
因为我们看到上两周的时候
就上上上上上周的时候就业数据非常差
所以市场现在基本上开始定价
我们叫做坏数据就是好数据
就是市场觉得连组可能会降息
那连组可能会降息
所以我们没有得到对于对于上一次坏数据的足够的定价
这是我的一个感觉
就是说当经济数据变差的时候
往往会经历这样的一个过程
包括我觉得这一波的这个现象和去年大概在7、8月份的时候很像
就是7、8月份一直到10月份
那最后是9月份说降了50个basis point
所以9月份降往50个basis point之后
其实市场还经历了一段时间下跌
就是最早时候大家开始先定价
经济数据不好
然后连组会降息
所以bad news is good news
然后之后就bad news is really bad news
就数据不好
那个东西就是差
然后公司盈利就会受影响
然后市场就开始下跌
这是两个不同阶段的东西
但是现在的整体的市场情况
我觉得和去年差不多这个时候的一个区别是
去年我坚定的认为经济基本面是没有问题的
那么我现在觉得经济基本面可能会有问题
所以去年其实反转并不完全是因为特朗普
去年的反转是因为经济数据
一方面是因为特朗普当选
然后市场觉得就是pro business的又回归了
那这是一方面
另外一个方面我觉得
fundamentally来说
本质上是因为经济数据并没有掉下去
就是大家觉得bad news is good news
然后要降息
降了息
然后bad news is bad news
这个数据差确实要变差
但是最后没有发生bad news
就是这个经济数据最后还是回来了
所以我们在去年的时候的
认为有几个方面的原因
第一个
in the immigration
那个有很多的移民
那第二个是government expenditure
政府在花钱
这一些原因都是导致了去年经济数据
我坚定的认为是不会掉下去的原因
那个因为政府占的扩张很快
然后政府占的扩张很快
相当于政府在花钱
那这种过程中间仅仅没有下去
但是今年到4月份的时候
可能这个我认为要从基本面来说
bad news的周期会更长
所以呢就是整个市场很有可能会
我觉得数据在下去的时候
市场很有可能会和去年8月份到10月份挺像
就是有一些调整
有基于基本面调整
但是这个事情也要根据我们在那个
就对于不同的投资标的
特别是对于半导体
对于高科技公司
那这些东西可能也要根据
整个高科技的Kapex的方向来改变
因为现在工资层面Kapex还是很猛的
我说一下苹果上周一些commitment
包括美国对于冥场
对于这个芯片的投入
那这些东西还是看上去还是挺稳的
所以你在Mega 7甚至最大的10个公司
你把阿巴国、TSM这些全部搭进来
最多这10个公司
它的走势其实更像2023年
就是2023年的时候是对于基本面的不确定性
还是挺强的
但是几个大公司的几个大公司比较看好
所以大公司在那里长
所以我是个人感觉接下去几个月
可能会有一些基本面调整
但是数据上要拭目以待
现在短期来说
到9月份联储会议之前
大家会更多的discussion
更多的讨论在通胀会怎么样
然后联储会过去降息
我觉得是这个事情上
那么上周没有很多的经济数角
没有把那个经济数
Economy Calendar给贴出来
更重要的是这周二要发布CPI的数据
今天美国是要出那个通胀数据
通胀这数据有一个focus
基本上像GOM和JP
是认为通胀数据会偏高的
我倾向于认为
通胀会受到这些一次性的
tariff关税的影响是会偏高的
那么它其实是有两方面的影响
一方面是tariff
第二方面是demand在变少
所以它是假带中间
但是tariff影响可能会更加重要一些
就是通胀数据可能没有那么高
但是影响出来的是说
市场会问
就是说我最后那个连储会不会去降息
那9月份降息的事情
我觉得概率还是蛮大的
就是无外乎我对于通胀的认知
是我认为通胀会偏高
偏向于JP和GOM的这个预测
那么但是我觉得还是很有可能会降息
这就是我上周
上周所谓也提过
对于美联储来说
数据上来美联储来说
那个增长的数据是重要于通胀数据
这个事情是确定的
那其实在上一周的话
我们衍生出来说一下
那个关于联储的一个态度
那个bomen出来说过
我上周的时候出来说
我倾向于要降三次
然后好像是两三周前吧
其实quizball也出来说过
那个时候调整的
labor
调整的就业数据还没有公开
所以当时我们看到的
能放配入数据还是不错
quizball也出来那个时候就讲
就是认为labor market比预期的要更差
然后第二个认为通胀的数据
相对来说是一字形的
不应该那么重视
在上一次联储会的时候
其实从1993年以来
非常罕见的有两个governor
descent
就是两个governor就是反对
反对后的人群
所以应该觉得这样行
那你要了解一下联储工作的机制
就是联储工作机制
它表示说在那个周二时候开会
周二开会的话
它其实在周一
其实已经有pre-meeting
等于是那个Jay Park
所有人打电话
已经说清楚你们的立场
到底怎么样
并不是在周二会议的时候
大家去决定这件事情
然后翻脸吵架
它一般来说在去开会之前
往往已经会把那个
它我的这个statement就写好了
所以在周一的时候
或最后沟通一次
Jay Park跟他们一个个打电话
其实在上一周的时候
Jay Park
这个大家已经已经沟通过了
所以在Jay Park
walking出这个会场的时候
为什么美联储你说大家开会
都是基本上是统一决定要怎么样
其实就说美联储
Jay Park会在决定之前
已经非常清楚每个
每个语会的委员的这个立场
然后该评合都已经评分过
该说服都说服过
大家出来就是发一个statement
然后把我们之前谈的东西
在会场形式走一下
那如果说在这个会议的时候
有两个descent
你有两个就是反对
那么其实就是代表联储内部
其实一方面可能是因为特朗普
一直在说节票
就是有一些委员可能
就是想反对你以前
对吧
就是不想合众
就想在特朗普面前表现一下
也有可能
但是至少来说
有两票反对
很明确的代表了一个点
就是联储那边的分级比较大
那这个是比较确定的
那接下去的数据会怎么样
那我觉得就接下去的数据
肯定会变得更长
所以这个descent力量已经很大了
在9月份的时候
它降息的压力其实非常大
就是我们来说降息的问题
就是我觉得第一个
降息是25个级点
它不会到50个级点
这是非常非常难到50个级点
但是它也很难不降息
那个降不降息
其实后面还有一组经济数据
那个在9月份之前
还有组经济数据
所以并不能说打保票
它就一定会降
但是降的概率会很大
因为联储内部的压力
其实已经出来了
其实即使我说Chris Waller的问题是
Chris Waller在即使这一次的
那个经济数据出来之前
其实已经说了
我们这个labor market很差
那我其实我们在每周的这个周会上面
我其实也一直在说
美国经济数据很差
美国经济的基本面
其实要调三级度
四级度经济数据不会特别好
就是这个是consensus
就是大家的一个怎么说呢
就是不是表面看经济数据的话
如果这些投资银行
或者是做研究的一个consensus
觉得经济数据是会下行的
经济数据下行
来自于几方面的压力
第一方面
government spending确实是减少了
你说减税或者是大美利法案
后面花钱
那个是后面的事情
你减税也要到11月份
所以确实前面
比方说我们看到
那个不同的sector的这个
不同的sector在那个government
就是这个上一周
我们看到那个不同的sector的
这个就业数据的变化
其实包括中间很多
education方面
确实是政府消费变少
那个它的工作岗位就变少
这是一方面
第二个呢
特朗普比较严厉的移民政策
使得已经在美国的移民
先说就是减少移民
肯定是减少消费的
这毫无疑问
移民的数量减少
这是影响
但是这个影响并没有那么大
影响比较大的
是已经在美国的一千万的移民
这些人的消费会下降
就是大家会担心
消费就是会下降
新的移民减少也是会下降
所以移民政策的
即使他那里瞎吼
喊大棒
也是会导致消费下降
第三方面就是说
特朗普就是关税
关税导致的
就是公司层面的
这个business sector的这个
hiring减少
就是我们其实前几个月
已经看到了他的这个
新增的岗位的减少
可能他并没有开除人
所以那个并没有大规模去减远
所以你在能放配若上面
还没有那么明显的感觉出来
但是前几个月
但是hiring的减少
新增岗位的减少
这已经是很明显
这个和移民也是有关的
和那个关税
我因为有关税
公司不敢去花钱
公司不敢去做新的开拍
这些东西也是有关的
这个说到
是不是四大云厂的开拍
四大云厂开拍是跟着token做的
这个东西确实没有较
就是还是很多
就是我们大会会讲高科技公司
就是你可能会看到
我们说在宏观层面
整个S&P指数层面
在公司层面
他的这个表现
我觉得可能会更像去年七八月
七八月份
但是呢
在科技公司呢
他的那个开拍又是确实要闷
那么你回想一下
去年八九月份
会有一个过程
就是一开始的时候
有一些公司业绩很好
然后大家又在pricing降息
应该不怕
就是你只要跌了我就买
比方说英伟达也是这样子
对吧
那么到了某一个市场的节点
市场当他开始认为
Bad data is bad data
那这种情况下
市场会把所有好的票也丢掉
就是我觉得好的票上涨
就是一个机会出头出好
那么这个时候也是
就是情绪的变化
是会比较快的
那就会变化
那等到稳定了以后
又觉得好的票把钱回来
所以我们可以去等一等
三四季度的经济数据
那我之前说过就是
如果说
四月份没有赶去赌政策
去加仓
我肯定自己没有加仓
然后涨上去我肯定不会追
但是在经济数据调整的情况下
如果S&P是有结果的
我觉得
后面看到AI的增长是比较明确的
后面看到Token的需求也是比较明确
对于半导体是很看好
就半导体高科技公司是很看好
现在我们对于通胀数据
不要特别去关注这个数据
会多大程度上影响美联储决定
我觉得没有影响那么大大
Global全球的产业过剩是很明显的
就包括中国
我什么说中国企业很难有马诊
很难有那个
很难有马诊
就是很难有那个盈利
中国的企业会有量
但它很难赚钱
就是中国所有的企业
其实它运行的模式都是跑量
把量跑出来找零号贷款
你可以看房地产
或者是各个工坊企业都是这个样子
因为Global来说全球需求不足
需求在哪里
需求在美国
所以美国企业是有盈利的
它是赚钱的
那么这个是完全不同的逻辑
那么在美国的高科技公司里面
我觉得后面几年
就是其实在这个CAPEX
是不太会降下去
所以我们是在宏观上面去找机会
在这个整个AI boom
想去找这个AI boom的入场的试点
我个人的看法
上周其实有几个
你可以看出
克朗普这个政府一个形式的一个规则
首先周末时候比较重要的几个点
第一个 把H20的芯片给中国开了
H20芯片给中国开了
首先H20肯定是上一代的缩减版
那么H系列的缩减版
那么H20芯片开了
对中国的AI肯定是一个很浪大利好
因为即使H20的芯片
华为的芯片是连编斗级不上
但它差得太远
那么但是我们其实
我内的新闻可能要再说一讲
就是它说H20芯片又不环保
又不先进 更不安全
那么这些新闻是有可能是爱国者制造的
就是国内可能想卖芯片
像华为这些人
对H20开了之后可能不胜满意
那这个每个人有自己的利益
因为他们一直是做爱国生意
华为一直是做爱国生意
那么但是你可以看出
特朗普政府的一个形式的原则
就是它把这个芯片给中国开了
对于中国AI肯定是有很大帮助的
但是美国特朗普KM它不太KM
它是说我给AMD和NVDN去收15%的税
那你就可以卖给中国人
这个是它一个很正常的形式逻辑
包括它在那个美国和俄国的这个问题上
就乌克兰的问题上
它是先说俄国你不停战
不停战的话
我8月8号就制裁你
那我8月8号制裁的时候
8月8号没有发出任何事情
然后到周末说
发一个Statement说8月15号
那个美国和特朗普
和那个普京要在阿拉斯加开封婚
所以他立马就踏口了
俄国没有停战
他没有做任何行为
然后美国就直接说8月15号
我总统跟你会面
跟你去谈判
这个可是美国入侵
不 美国就是俄国入侵乌克兰之后
就从来就没有发生的事情
没有跟你谈的
所以它的这个态度
就是一般来说
就这也是在它
包括你们看到它对Intel的处理的
今天早上
他不是跟那个Lipote
跟李承宁舞去会谈了
所以当特朗普挥舞起大棒的时候
你就知道他就要踏口了
他肯定是要踏口
他只是挥舞一下大棒
表现自己在马卡人面前
哎 我很强 我很strong 厉害
只是这个而已
但是Navidian的芯片和AMD的芯片
对中国开放
那么首先对于中国本土的
那些华为之类的制造上
是很大的打击
因为它的这个芯片
肯定是比你先前很多
那么第二个
我觉得是代表
台湾普政府的一个态度
一个政策
但是对于英伟达的这个业绩
有多大影响
我觉得也没有特别大影响
因为本身
本身中国一直在囤它的那个H系列芯片
一系列芯片
就是这个国内的算力是严重补足
美国算力多不足
国内的算力是严重补足
大家一直在走色
既然国内的包括Deep Seek
他们Deep Seek坚决的走了一条模仿
抄袭那个GPT的路径
但是他走了抄袭路径
他连去抄人家的算力
可能都不一定够
所以这个芯片这个事情
它并不是开放不开放
就是它是一个完全的卖放市场
Token的需求太大了
就从美国全球来说
Token的需求增长太宽
那个完全是一个卖放的市场
就是TSMC不够生产
那个大家去抢它的现成
英伟达强的最多
它是这么一个市场
那么你回过来看
上周同时另外一个新的
就是那个苹果说投6000亿在美国
苹果投6000亿在美国
其实这个事情有人也说过
就是那个苹果在每一任的时候
都会放出一个很大的投资表递
你不用去认为苹果说
我把产业连搬到美国去
他就搬了过去
他不是的
它这个6000亿中间
包括最近的近期的是1000亿
后面是长远的规划是6000亿
这个中间呢
其实投入Data Center
酸力中心这些全算了
所以酸力中心投资
对于这些大的公司来说
是一个必备的
每家都要去投
所以这个并不是说
它会能够把中国的产业连搬过去
我觉得这个也不太可能
但是在苹果要投6000亿
他们搞Starkade要搞个5000亿
这种就是它不是和那个孙真亿
他们一起搞和Open AI一起搞
要去搞5000亿
在这个大的环境下面
英特尔去说我要亮录为初
就是那个Lipton说亮录为初
其实更多的是对英特尔过往的
无限的投资
那个一个反思
是一个文化的反思
并不完全说那个Lipton
叫把那个陈立五
就是要把英特尔的整个现成
18亿要停掉
14亿要停掉
并不是这样的
它也是一方面是内部的政治
就是把原来的CEO的事情
要检讨一下
第二个就是要说一下
我们以后的文化
你要更加亮录为初
更加解解
然后同时的话要考虑盈利
更加考虑盈利
但是在大的形式上的和
特朗普的政策肯定是不太相符的
我要搞大明大放大越境
你在那里搞亮录为初
所以周我住死了
特朗普说陈立五应该立马辞职
So resign immediately
这这个是他发的
那个true social的这个原话
所以昨天晚上
就是应该是刚刚吧
就是美国时间刚刚吧
那个立普谈就准备的东西
去准备了一个文件
然后去跟特朗普谈判
我这没放进去
Trump跟他谈完以后
Trump的意思就是
哎
意思就是说这个陈立五
还是有一个非常好
Interesting的这个经历的
我的团队跟英采会有更多的这个
谈判
更多的进一步的
就是怎么progress的这个东西
所以我觉得很可能的结果呢
就是他非常希望
因为英特尔是美国的长
就相当于美利坚共和国的长者
那个他非常希望英特尔
能够继续去投资
然后继续去在他那个
大越境中间搬远角色
那么前这个事情
其实government sponsor
对于对于美国现在来说
钱不是什么问题
就是这个不是什么问题
所以对英特尔来说
我觉得Trump的政策
是不可能把陈立五赶下台
把陈立五赶下台
那英特尔这公司就
我觉得短期里面就不用看了
因为英特尔现在缺的
并不是Foundry的那个良率
他缺的是Foundry能够跟第三方对接
能够怎么样去服务第三方
跟第三方对接
有人在上面做开放
作为Keylence原来的CEO
然后那个Lipotent的陈立五
我觉得是一个非常非常好的人选
而且他对英特尔很了解
你要再去换一下CEO
再折腾一下
那这个公司可能就这两年就就费掉
所以我觉得这个可能应该很小
就是真的把陈立五赶走
这些可能应该相当来说比较小
所以Trump的policy
你就看一看就好
对于S&P的估值
我是认为就回到我刚刚讲到
整个风险市场的估值
我觉得对于S&P的估值
现在是偏高的
在现在的经济情况下是偏高的
因为我们今年和明年还是pricing
这是狗们的一个预计
还是pricing了7%的Early Growth
百分之接Early Growth不算很小
24年就10%
这个是市场对它的一个定价
但是你在整个如果三季度
四季度经济数据变差的情况下
其实这个7%不是那么容易达成的
那这个7%中间包括了我们的高科技公司
会有WDG Growth
会增长更多
然后会给出更好的Early Growth
那么对于很多的其他的公司
它的数据可能会更差
所以我觉得这个走势下来
我觉得是高科技公司
靠的是Tapax 靠的是投资推动
然后需要靠消费和靠数据的公司
可能后面的引力会受到一些影响
这是我个人的感觉
然后市场的position的话
我最后简单说一下是CTA的position
CTA的position没有前两个上个月这么明显
CTA的position我觉得现在是mix
就是涨的话它会继续上升
等我一下不好意思
还有个东西
就CTAposition我觉得现在相对比较mix
那个是可以有很大下调的环节
因为上两个月包括Sysmaniposition
包括CTA其实有很大的投存进入市场
那个在Global CTA现在已经到了150个别列
在美国的到了54个别列
那么这种情况下就是我觉得
就是flow整体是mix的
就是比较不确定性的
那么公司的回购这两个接下去
几个星期85%的公司还是开着的
所以还能够延续一段时间
那么在所以整个市场情绪
我觉得可能在大家pricing bad data
is good data的过程当天还会延续一下
但是很有可能到了9月前
或者大家对于降息会比较敲定的时候
我觉得可能会开始有一波调整
每一次其实降息是开启
就是经济数就不好
降息是开启调整的
它不是降息之后就开始市场涨
我觉得过往的经历比较多的是降息
以后开始调整
所以我觉得可以如果没有进场
我觉得可以等降息以后
市场怎么走再看一看
好吧
我大致这样说一下
然后看下大家后面有什么问题
我们可以提问一下